I love you Mary Jane all right back into
it
hey you know I just got 10,000
subscribers [ __ ] yeah
I can't believe we did it I mean I
probably lost pinta I'm back to 9,000
after talking about politics for an
episode and also saying that I prefer
other characters to miles so you know
all right I promise I want to talk about
that no more after after we had our our
little discussion about it in the
comments unless it says people like
calling each other names in which case
that's probably bad I don't know I think
I have more faith in you guys than that
I'm recording like six or seven parts in
a row so I'm going to run out of comm
I'm going to run out of questions to
answer at some point unless I take
another break for another recording
session good lord I am having a real
hard time getting up this wall hey
what's up if you guys seem Logan it's
really good probably like I don't know
top three best comic book movies ever
for me not favorite but bad like it is
just objectively like a really solid
movie really liked it because it it's
good as a movie and not just a superhero
movie like if you if you don't give a
[ __ ] about comic books Avengers really
that interesting it's just a bunch of
characters you don't you don't really
like that much just interacting I don't
know I kind of live in a bubble and I
like 90% of these movies just because I
have like a connection to the source
material so I I mean I'm in a bubble in
that respect I don't know and I guess
you guys are too because if you're
watching me ramble about spider-man and
[ __ ] for however many parts then clearly
you like comic books too so
I'll have to find someone who just
absolutely does not care at all like you
know what Kyle if you've seen my
previous heavy rain let's play then
you've you've met Kyle he doesn't hate
comic books it's just something that
he's never ever gotten into so I might
actually show him like some random comic
book movies and see what he thinks of
them having no real connection to the
source material because he has like
nothing to like help him form an opinion
it's just like the movies gonna be all
again okay what's this since a comment
or sure is have I done this one already
I might have I don't know I don't think
I have here I'm going to open a soda
it's going to be really loud unless I
like lower the audio digitally the
mei-hua bong are highly trained martial
artists who controls the downtown area
with an iron fist
mei-hua ba is Unicare among New Yorkers
Ganga's in that it bosses are all family
I don't know it sounds funny in my head
when I started doing it have I done this
one already I think I have [ __ ] if I've
done this one already I'm wasting so
much time let's see here now wait
doesn't tell you oh stop blocking how
are you blocked you're not ah here hold
on let's let splits exit this one I have
to check because I might be wasting tons
of recording time have I done that one
previously also why did it put me all
the way back over there
how can you tell which ones you've done
already doesn't it doesn't say unless
they disappear after you do them for the
first time which I don't think they do
let's go do that one over on the water
just to be safe okay what other
questions do I have
spider-man ps4 suits
I want Tom Hollands suit in there even
though it's like I don't know I have a
sort of nostalgia Singh for Tobey
Maguire spider-man suit so if they're
willing to put that in there then sure I
don't think they will put those suits in
because people will probably just like
the default suit in spider-man ps4 is
kind of controversial because the design
has so much white on it and is like it's
just out of the norm for the way
spider-man looks and if they put in
alternate costumes to dresses like Tom
Hollands spider-man or Tobey spider-man
or comic spider-man whatever people are
most likely just going to put that one
on and leave it on because why would you
not be the spider-man you're used to why
would you be this new one with the big
dumb white logo you know and while I
like the ps4 design I absolutely know
why everyone else does not I mean I've
explained it in that ps4 that spider-man
ps4 video I did so you know that's
that's a concern I have about AI makes
me think that they won't put alternate
costumes in just for the sake of like
people using the ones that they give you
to start with but if they do put in
other costumes I'd love to see you know
the Sam Raimi spider-man definitely Tom
Hollands spider-man just because really
you like have to swap out the bottom
half of the costume and didn't you
wouldn't even have to model a different
mask
you know I I really like the black suit
I mean I think it was a little bit
overused in the videogames in the 2000
but now that it's been a while since
I've seen it I kind of miss it again
and maybe they could be like something I
like new version of it I don't know then
Riley's suit is really cool like not the
most recent one that just looks like
spider hot spider slide with a hood the
mouth on that mask is stupid looking and
I don't know what they were thinking
when they decide to do that but um yeah
I like Ben Riley's costumes for the most
part like even the silly Scarlet Spider
which is just like it's basically just
like what spider-man would do if he
couldn't if he didn't have enough money
for his usual costume so you just get
like a red bodysuit puts the eyes on it
and then just like wears a hoodie over
it so it's not so he doesn't look like a
naked red guy yeah yeah I guess Ben
Riley is a villain now or something but
I guess they're also going to undo that
immediately making it pointless where he
has to be like yeah it's the idea of
Scarlet Spider becoming a good guy again
after losing himself a little in doing
evil things that's really cool but
didn't we do that already with Kane you
could just not bring the clone stuff
back you could just pretend it didn't
happen like everyone else does dan and
company dan all right well anyway Oh
more mission
is this a venom mission I'm doing next I
can't even remember which one I'm doing
next I think it's the one where he
breaks out of shield so then why mean I
shouldn't spoil unless it's just one of
those really pointless ones or it's like
yeah spider-man gets home he calls Mary
Jane and talks with her on the phone and
then and then goes back to his normal
business because those ones kind of
pissed me off because they're kind of
like it's not a mission it's just here's
a cup team you did the combat tour for
nothing one thing I want from spider-man
ps4 is I want Peter Parker stuff in it
because that's something that's really
been kind of largely unexplored by the
previous games like I know amazing
spider-man 2 gave it a try but it was
just kind of like it was just sit here
and then hit all the buttons for these
dialogue options and it wasn't really
options it was just like here's a list
of them and nothing changes if you say
one before the other like there was no
real interactivity it was just like a
cutscene you know with really long
drawn-out dialogue and then you just hit
a button every couple of seconds to keep
it going it or you can just skip over it
entirely which again that's it's not fun
so like how about a mission where you
have to run around in the city as Peter
Parker taking photos of things and then
also have to find like a spot where no
one can see you to change into your
spider food I wonder is there a
connection between the suit and society
when Spiderman came on the scene seemed
that you were more focused on him than
the target we told you to test the game
when he was there spider-man I felt like
the suit was under control
I felt good just being in proximity to
spider-man why would that be
it happened one other time Parker Parker
Richard Parker he dead but his son is
not the suit was built with Richard
Parker's DNA and his son is fiber and
getting close to him is giving Brock
more control a little suit get Brock to
tell you everything
Hanny Queens still in high school and
here Thomas eat of his own free wrist
no I don't think we have to worry about
that what the hell are you doing
[Music]
[Music]
Eddie Brock is not I need backup at my
location ASAP
[Music]
all right silver sable your ass is grass
and I I'm probably going to forget too
much and bad with Jordan
how does she jump so far she like she
have superpowers in this universe that
I'm not aware of what's that how did you
kick me over here I'm gonna keep eating
civilians piss you off or you know I
guess you don't care
ask that we mean area unavailable with a
railing
and it's like you just beat yourself I
just have to like stand I just throw
cars at you and you stand next to them
and wait for them to explode now I hate
flash love that you can hear people
muffled inside of the cars like
screaming because you threw them can you
not pick her up telling some of those
like best attacks or when you pick up
the bad guy I'm not even at half health
and you begging for food then of you are
a glutton for both human human essence
and punishment can I not go over here I
need any tokens though you see those
tokens right I need them all right fine
I guess I'll just stay over in this area
the tokens can wait
oh if he stayed next to that I would one
alright here doing your thing I'm gonna
head on over here and go look for some
more huh what I call mortals Hey
delicious hey I went to Benihana to
celebrate the 10,000 subscribers
I didn't invite like a whole bunch of
people though today I feel like that
would be kind of annoying like yeah you
made a bunch of YouTube video good free
[ __ ] losers but no like I celebrated
a little you know David and I also got a
cool thing coming up where uh because
I'm at 10,000 subscribers and he's
almost hitting 300 we're going to review
a thing for each other so he gave me
like a grab bag of random Star Trek
episodes to make a video about that no
one will watch
we return what is left
okay it is my recollection that I kind
of suck at this mission unless I
magically don't know so I suppose be
alright but I mean David job because
he's hitting 360 issue the Punisher max
because that's like my favorite comic
one ever and also because like you
imagine him reviewing Punisher max with
his while that guy can fly but with his
delicate sensibilities like I
specifically was like here's the darkest
[ __ ] and weirdest book ever I can't
wait for him to get with the schemes of
Barracuda although I'm kind of half
expecting him to just kind of skim read
it and not actually pay attention
anything happening in it and then just
tell me yeah it kind of sucks know the
characters were relatable I mean yeah
you don't exactly friend Castle is not
relatable he is a serial killers kind of
if you think about it but it's not the
point I don't know we'll see hopefully
he doesn't just dismiss it and go yeah
suck and then and then the video is four
minutes long because I'm putting a lot
of effort into that Star Trek review
that no one's gonna watch I I'm getting
the green-screen out I'm getting
costumes yeah it's gonna be great
I will say the sound effect thing is a
little silly that it has you know how
much on my choppa choppa running across
the screen my god I don't know about
that one
I like the cutscene style but that one's
a little silly
just let me slap you there you know and
you I will throw things in
sometimes the explosion effect on the
helicopter glitches so they kind of
don't explode and that's that's one
whoops damn it I just threw that wrong
okay I get a mulligan on that there you
go that one looks good I mean you know
as good as 2005 perceivable oh hey what
are you doing in here that's not helpful
with the mission hide - benches shootin
okay pretty you know I'm glad that no
superheroes feel like intervening in
this even though this is like a giant
thing happening like six blocks are
being attacked by both venom and a small
a small army as well as a bunch of
helicopters like you think shield would
be like all over this you guys would be
like dead five seconds Oh like that what
happened alright that okay well [ __ ]
walk off alright I guess I'll try that
again
remember that time Aunt May died but not
really